>> Tucker: THE WAR ON CHRISTMAS
IS FAKE.
THEY TELL YOU THAT ON TV.
BUT IT'S ALSO UNDERWAY AGAIN.
A HOT START LAST WEEK WITH THE
LEFT LAUNCHING A NEW OFFENSIVE
AGAINST THE RED NOSED REINDEER.
NOW AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL IN NEBRASKA BANNED
CHRISTMAS RELATED ITEMS.
CHRISTMAS TREES, SANTA AND RED
AND GREEN COLOR COMBINATIONS.
NO CANDY CANES.
THEY ARE IN THE SHAPE OF A J
WHICH REPRESENTS JESUS.
MARK STEIN JOINS US TONIGHT.
THE WAR ON CHRISTMAS IS NOT
REAL.
STOP TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH.
FAC
FICTITIOUS.
I WILL BEAT ON THAT.
-- BITE ON.
SEPARATION OF CHURCH AND STATE
THEY DIDN'T WANT PRESIDENT
WASHINGTON TO BE THE HEAD OF THE
CHURCH LIKE THE QUEEN OF ENGLAND
IS.
LIKE A LOT OF SANE CONCEPTS IT
CHANGED INTO SOMETHING INSANE.
WHEN YOU ARE BANNING COLORS AND
TWO OF THE COLORS ON THE COLOR
SPECTRUM, RED AND GREEN, SO
THERE IS ONLY ORANGE, YELLOW AND
BLUE LEFT.
YOU ARE BONKERS.
YOU ARE NUTS.
YOU HAVE FLOWN THE COOP OF
REALITY.
YOU ARE LIVING IN A MORE BIZARRE
FANTASY THAN SANTA AND HIS ELVES
BEING EVER COME UP WITH.
>> Tucker: A PROFESSOR TWEETED
THAT MARY THE VIRGIN COULD NOT
CONSENT TO THE CONCEPTION OF
CHRIST.
HE DECK
HE DECORATED HIS TREE IS SATANIC
ORNAMENTS.
DID YOU TAKE ANY OF HIS CLASSES?
>> NO, THE IDEA THAT GOD HAS
GOTTEN THE VIRGIN MARY BACK TO
HIS PATH AND SHE IS SAYING I
REALLY MUST GO AND HE IS SAYING
IT'S COLD OUTSIDE.
PUT SOME RECORDS ON WHEN I POUR.
I MISS THE DAYS WHEN ATHIESTS
WERE INTELLIGENCE ENOUGH TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY WHAT THEY WERE TRYING
TO KNOCK DOWN.
THIS IS A DISMAL COMMENT ON THE
STATE OF ATHEISTS IN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: THEY NEVER CRITICIZED
JEFF BEZOS.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES
COUNTER-CULTURAL.
>> AND THEY DON'T MAKE THE SAME
RAMADAN JOKES AS CHRISTMAS
JOKES.
>> Tucker: THIS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROFESSOR IS NOT
ATTACKING MOHAMMED?
>> NO,NO.
THIS IS CARDBOARD.
FROM TEACHERS.
EVEN IF YOU ARE AN ATHEIST,
WESTERN MUSIC ART AND PAINTING
WERE IN THE COURSE OF
CHRISTIANITY.
>> Tucker: THE UNIVERSITY WOULD
NOT EXIST WITHOUT IT.
>> NO.